Morning John
One of the things I saw a lot
mentioned in the census, as I've been reading through it
is that people want to hear more about our adult-y lives doing the things that we do
and another thing I know, just about the world is that we celebrate our own successes and other people's successes,
but we don't talk about failure at all.
And it's kind of a taboo topic.
Its hard to ask other people to talk about their failures
And its hard to talk about your own
And it makes it feel like failure is unique
and when you experience it, like no one ever has. Because no one else has ever talked about it
Well John!
As you know, I am currently in the midst of something of a failure
So, I have this company that aims to celebrate nerdy things in the world
By taking them off of the internet for a little bit of time
And into the real world!
VidCon, of course, being the thing that started this all off
But, we also want to celebrate other nerdy things that people are passionate about
In particular,  I started NerdCon Stories
Because stories are this amazing thing that defines culture.
It's how we build our culture. How we decide how we are going to talk about our selves and our world
And this is the way which NerdCon Stories, this year, will not be a failure
We've sold about a thousand tickets
Which means there is going to be a huge, diverse, interesting group of people
Celebrating storytellers and stories
There is a ton of community generated and community focused content
So it's not just about the big names that are going to be there
It's about all of the people who are attending the conference,
all being the reason that all of the people who are there are attending
But, we budgeted the conference to have three thousand attendees
That's how many we sort of needed to make it work financially
We have a thousand
So, at this point, NerdCon Stories
Which I, as a human person, own
Stands to lose a lot of money
Now I can afford this
NerdCon is not going to go bankrupt
I'm not gonna go in to debt
But it does sting
I'm learnin' a lot
Through this whole process
But I do wish it was a slightly less expensive set of lessons
Ahh, Talking about it is not a good feeling!
That's why people don't do it!
You want to portray to the world this image of
Like, Ahh so good at th..bu..not!
Nobodies like that! Nobodies lives are like that!
Last year at NerdCon Stories was such a wonderful experience for me
And I'm very sad that I can't be there again this year
Especially since its probably going to be the last time NerdCon Stories happens
And I think this year, it's going to be a fantastic time for everybody who's there
And, really, that's, like, isn't that the thing that matters?
If you'd like to attend the event, or even just check it out, see maybe if you'd like to,
It's in Minneapolis
And I know lots of people can't go, for all kinds of very good reasons
Just to say to you, Make sound financial decisions.
You, right there, you are you first responsibility
But, if you are interested in checking it out
I, we've created a discount code
Discount Code: DFTBA
20% off. Twenty bucks off
Because, you know, What do we have to lose?
So I'm not proud that I've made a bunch of, of thought errors
Or just misunderstandings of how this event could go
And I might make a video over on "hankschannel" discussing all of those mistakes
So that you don't have to explain them to me in the comments, I know.
But, I'm very proud of the idea of this thing and a thing that we put together
And I'm very glad that it's going to be a thing that happened in the world
We've got John Green Yoga Adventure happening one morning
We've got opportunities for in depth conversations with professional authors
Live gaming, community sourced content
A live episode of Dear Hank & John
Though the Hank isn't going to be there
Workshops on 'zines, puppetry, improv, podcasting
And panels on diversity, adaptation, even tabletop gaming
As I list these things, I totally get that NerdCon Stories is a really weird event
And that probably doesn't work in its favor.
This is, among the mistakes that were made
But it's also, kind of the reason we're not going to pull the plug on this thing
Iw'll We're gonna keep it alive
We're gonna do it, even though its gonna lose me a bunch of money
This show must go on, because it's different and I think, special
And maybe that's the thing we could all be going for
Like, we're all going to fail sometimes
We're gonna make stuff, and it's not gonna to work
Even when we fail
Is there a way to eliminate the shame of that
And instead make it a failure you can be proud of?
John, I'll see you on Tuesday
I'mmab I'mma be okay
Video on "hankschannel", more in depth